[Musique]
n'est venu à 24,60 hors série sur le 50e
anniversaire de la crise d'octobre
mon invité jean laporte fils du ministre
pierre laporte qui a été enlevée et
assassinée lors de cette crise
revenons sur ces événements qui ont mené
à ce moment marquant le soir du 13
octobre 70 après des années ponctuées
d'incidents violents menés par le front
de libération du québec flq intensifie
son recours à la violence dans sa lutte
contre le colonialisme et le capitalisme
le diplomate britannique james cross est
enlevé le 5 octobre par la cellule
libération
c'est le premier enlèvement politique au
québec on ne possède aucun indice
nouveau quant au sort de l'attaché
commercial de grande bretagne à montréal
monsieur jean fred reid cross qui a été
kidnappé ce matin par quatre individus
armés
elle exige la diffusion du manifeste du
flq pour exposer ses revendications
notamment la libération de 23
prisonniers dits politiques pour des
raisons humanitaires qui leur est
évident de reçus des développements des
derniers jours et afin de sauver si
possible la vie de l'attaché commercial
de grande bretagne ce jeans l'étude
crasse nous faisons lecture intégrale du
manifeste du front de libération du
québec grande victoire pour la ftq
gaétan montreuil
li se manifeste sur les ondes de radio
canada le soir du 8 octobre
le manifeste dénonce les inégalités
sociales économiques subies par les
canadiens français de l'époque le samedi
10 octobre le ministre de la justice
jérôme choquette répond à l'ultimatum
des felquistes attirent peu de
concessions ultime pour sauver la vie de
monsieur ross le gouvernement fédéral
mais forme qu'il est disposé à vous
offrir le chauve conduit vers un pays
étranger
dès qu'ils entendent les mots sont
conduits les membres d'une autre cellule
la cellule chénier passe à l'action et
enlève devant sa maison le vice premier
ministre et ministre du travail pierre
laporte rapidement la famille laporte
la femme de monsieur kraus et des
membres du cabinet de robert bourassa
dont le premier ministre lui-même sont
confinées pour leur sécurité à l'hôtel
reine elizabeth à montréal
les 11 octobre pierre laporte écrit une
lettre à robert bourassa dans laquelle
il dit décide de ma vie ou la mort nous
tenons tous est il besoin de le dire à
la vue de monsieur laporte de même qu'à
celle de monsieur crasse mes chers
concitoyens je me battrai pour cette
justice jusqu'à la limite de mes moyens
en assumant tous les risques quel qu'il
soit et qui sont essentiels à l'avenir
de notre part le 13 octobre à savoir
l'armée se déploie autour des ambassades
et des édifices gouvernementaux
interrogé par un journaliste qui lui
demande jusqu'où il est prêt à aller
pour résoudre la crise le premier
ministre du canada pierre elliott
trudeau lance alors cette célèbre phrase
mais jeudi 15 octobre une assemblée au
centre paul sauvé a marial rassemble
point d'une minute à
on va s'organiser intelligemment on va
choisir nos terres et nous fêtons le
débordement de cette manifestation
peuvent laisser croire à une révolte
populaire
cela deviendra la raison officielle pour
proclamer la loi des mesures de guerre
ce sont des membres du flq rien ne
serait pas justifié le mal qui pourrait
être fait ces deux hommes ainsi qu'un
malheur quelque chose
mais le gouvernement pour faire face en
volage et la responsabilité nous est
apparu évident lorsque les risques
d'anarchie contrer une nouvelle
dimension
hier matin le gouvernement n'avait tout
simplement pas le choix que de faire ce
qu'il a fait c'est à dire de donner des
pouvoirs spéciaux aux forces policières
de manière à protéger leur public
proclamée au beau milieu de la nuit
cette loi qui rend hors la loi le flq de
nos policiers des pouvoirs
extraordinaires de perquisitions
d'arrestation et de détention depuis
vendredi le 16 octobre 4 heures du matin
environ 400 personnes ont été arrêtées à
peu près 250 ont été relâchés depuis
[Musique]
le lendemain le samedi 17 octobre
car la porte est assassiné son corps est
retrouvé dans le coffre d'une voiture à
saint-hubert le ministre québécois du
travail et d'immigration monsieur pierre
laporte assassiné par le front de
libération du québec samedi dernier a
été inhumé en fin d'après midi à
montréal
le repaire de la cellule libération qui
détiennent james cross est encerclée et
le 3 décembre des négociations mais n'te
à l'exil des ravisseurs vers cuba
après deux mois de captivité jam the
witcher crois c'est finalement libéré le
28 décembre
les autorités arrêtent les frères rose
et francis simard de la cellule chénier
cellule qui avait revendiqué dans un
communiqué l'exécution du ministre
cinquante ans plus tard deux grandes
questions demeurent que retenir de cette
page sombre de notre histoire
quelles leçons en tirer at on choisi
entre frapper un grand coup au détriment
de la vie de pierre laporte
voici la réponse de son fils jean dans
l'entrevue qu'il nous a accordé
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'accepter nous
parler d'un événement dramatique tant
pour votre histoire personnelle que pour
pour le québec 50 ans après vous aviez
11 en deux soirs d'enlèvement de votre
père vous avez 61 ans maintenant
qu'est-ce que ce qu'est ce que
représentent ces cinquante années de vie
pour vous c'est toute une vie c'est
toute une vie c'est beaucoup de journées
c'est c'est de faire partie si malgré
soi de l'histoire du québec et c'est des
souvenirs c'est des blessures c'est un
cheminement personnel et une croissance
il le fait aussi de 200 répliques
souvent lorsqu'on pas sur le pont tout
ce qu'on voit les écoles ou autres
boulevards de mai au nom de son père
entre l'enfant de 11 ans que vous étiez
est l'homme que vous êtes devenu avec
tout ce qu'on a dit nous pu lire voir
sur la crise d'octobre donc votre
sentiment at il évolué et qu'elle est il
maintenant oh mon dieu
à 11 ans vous perdez votre père vous
perdez la personne qui est sans doute
avec boîte noire la plus importante de
votre vie mais avec les années et en
affaires et à prendre des décisions
peser le pour et le contre
vous regardez ça avec une distance avec
je pense une perspective différente de
gestionnaire et vous voyez que le
gouvernement du québec de ce moment à
l'eau et fédérales ont pris des
décisions en fonction de l'avenir et des
décisions long terme qui sans doute
condamné quelqu'un d'important
concrètement plus clairement ça veut
dire qu'on aurait pu sauver votre père
qu'on le peut sauver parce que ça sert l
intérêt supérieur de l'addition été
prise de ne pas négocier pour tuer dans
l'âme les faits le cul qui avaient déjà
pris place au québec qui
elle est contre la démocratie du québec
et des personnes ont fait des choix au
niveau des gouvernements n'ont pas
d'utiliser la situation mais de de
manipuler ou de maximiser pour que
l'avenir du québec et du canada soient
plus faciles à contrôler et de limiter
les excès de ce groupe révolutionnaire
par le biais de la négociation qui a
mené à l'assassinât et à la peur de mon
père c'est lourd ça ça vous le réalisez
maintenant la vie réelle au fil des
années au fond on ne trahit votre père
l'abandonné on le sacrifier je voudrais
plus le mot sacrifie triste note un
autre point de vue mais sacrifiées pour
ce que les gens pourraient dire la bonne
cause mais c'est rare qu au québec et au
canada on puisse décider volontairement
ou non mais là vous savez que en
affaires la non action est une décision
vous prenez des décisions et le fait de
pas en prendre tous une décision alors
la non-action les négociations qui
auraient pu amener à sa libération pour
moi est une décision qui a été prise
mon ne laissait croire à votre père
qu'on négocier il tellement cru qu'il a
écrit à robert bourassa qui laiterie à
votre mère le lundi 12 octobre
d'ailleurs cette émission est diffusée
le lundi 12 octobre
cinquante ans après mais je pense que
tant que vous négociez l'espoir et si
jamais j'avais quelqu'un qui serait dans
une situation qui serait la même
situation j'aurais aussi le goût de
donner de l'espoir
sachant que ce n'est pas terminée tant
qu'il ya des opportunités que tant que
des chances de riz d'une situation il ya
de l'espoir et à partir du moment où il
est plus d'espoir c'est qu'il ya puis de
négociation c'est qu'il y ait plus de
vie alors il est normal que et et pierre
laporte un optimus pire la porte un
combattant père la porte quelqu'un qui
voyait les solutions il ya mais les
problèmes pour trouver les solutions et
c'est pour ça je pense que le feu
de l'optimisme est un peu
d'encouragement envers la famille dans
la dette qu'on a reçu concrètement si un
de ses traits de caractère il disait
être prêt à être au travail on est 24
heures il implorait les gouvernements
mais la lettre est à robert bourassa
alors le gros des décisions tourné en 3
il implorait les gouvernements de faire
confiance aux ravisseurs que de négocier
or on a appris après coup les dessous de
ces négociations non négociation et même
marc lalonde isère on ne peut pas
négocier parce que ça aurait pu même
monsieur trudeau a dit le prochain ça va
être un gérant caisse populaire mais ça
c'est ça ça arrive au moment de la
proclamation de la loi des mesures de
guerre six jours après l'enlèvement de
votre père ça a dû provoquer et on pense
à provoquer chez d'une grande détresse
quand le gouvernement fédéral dit qu'il
ne peut pas négocier mais qu'il négocie
pour le sucre à son époque monsieur
laporte
ça peut être perçu d'un deux poids deux
mesures oui je pense que ce le fut deux
poids deux mesures spéciales en lien
avec les intentions des deux chacune des
cellules parce que je n'étais davantage
décidé à exécuter votre père et l'autre
est dit on n'a jamais eu l'intention de
tuer le support je n'ai aucune idée de
ce que les cellules pensée ou faisait ce
pommeau rôle mais ce que je sais c'est
que monsieur cross a été libérée il ya
des négociations et pierre laporte n'a
pas été libérée a été assassiné mais
capital apporté un côté nationaliste qui
sans doute ne plaisait pas beaucoup aux
fédéralistes yougman du data one et je
pense qu'il veut - d'ottawa une beaucoup
de décisions à prendre le grand air du
québec a suivi par la suite alors ils
avaient sans doute soucieux de pouvoir
le pied dans la place il ya cinquante
ans le gouvernement canadien pourrait
décision monsieur trudeau avec son
fameux i just watch met aussi en scène
c'est elle allie mesures c'était la loi
des mesures de guerre
on sait par différents apports dans
qu'être que dans la cellule libération
qui ont des monsieur kraus quand ils ont
vu l'adoption de la loi des mesures de
guerre
aucune des personnes présentes dit la
porte est mort la cellule libération qui
détenait monsieur croiser est convaincu
que la loi des mesures de guerre elle
est entraîné une radicalisation du côté
de la cellule chénier
donc on peut pas ce que vous aller
jusqu'à dire que le gouvernement
canadien aurait dû prévoir savoir que
cette radicalisation la diffusion
l'association politique il faudrait
retourner 50 en arrière les intervenants
qu'est-ce qu'ils devaient défendre et de
façon qu'ils n'ont fait leur décision
fait partie de ce tour maintenant comme
je vous dis pour moi ça a été la perte
de mon père c'était la peur de pierre
laporte et peu importe les décisions
peu importe le fait que la loi des
mesures de guerre est rendue plus
radicale d'une cellule ou non moi je
pense à la base quand vous enlevez
quelqu'un vous êtes responsable de sa
vie
peu importe le reste des événements
alors basé sur sa loi des mesures de
guerre ou non yapo négociations ue décès
a pour moi c'est l'analyse rapide mais
simple de ce qui s'est passé avec les
deux niveaux de gouvernement
est ce que un gouvernement a le droit de
penser que c'est le négocier des
terroristes il va aggraver la situation
est ce que vraiment ça n'a pas de coeur
d'une certaine manière je pense que le
tout était pesé le tout était décidé et
mis en place pour que la sortie de la
crise d'octobre qui s'est passé
rapidement et dont on a fermé
l'histoire rapidement entre l'enlèvement
la loi des mesures de guerre
le décès l'an terme ça s'est passé en
moins de deux semaines
je pense que ça a été
dirigé d'une main de gens qui voulaient
rêver à une fin du mouvement
pour améliorer le futur du québec et du
canada et que la décision est prise on
peut négocier pour supporter cette
vision des choses pour séparatisme et et
aurait une seule et même chose dont
l'écrasent je pense qu'il ya 50 ans du
temps du flq
il y avait beaucoup de liens entre
certaines personnes qui étaient pour le
mouvement séparatiste et d'autres pour
la force pour y arriver il effectue
voulait prendre ce chemin là et des
personnes en place ont décidé qu'il ya
peut-être des façons d'amener la volonté
populaire de notre côté et d'enrayer la
force dans le cheminement du québec vers
l'indépendance donc cinquante ans plus
tard le sentiment qui vous anime à
penser qu'on ne sacrifier votre père
qu'on a pris des décisions qu'elle est
de part et d'autre on l'enlève
on est prêt jusqu'à l'exécution et si on
vous vers nous on est prêt à sacrifier
cds des deux côtés aussi il ya eu des
surnoms lève 1 on a pris la décision
d'enlever un être humain politique
une décision majeure qui est là 2 une
fois qu'on a enlevé on est responsable
et 3 qui peut être perçu comme normal de
vouloir sauver la vie d'un être humain
et d'un politicien et du vice-premier
menace du québec
pour moi ce serait logique de faire ça
il semble pas que ce soit ce que ce soit
arrivé
et pourtant il y avait des leaders dans
la société civile je pense à rené
lévesque claude ryan alfred rouleau
on les appelait le groupe des 16 qui ont
fait un point de presse un moment donné
pour supplier les gouvernements négocier
et à ottawa on le dit aussi farfelue on
a créé un coup d'état
est-ce qu'on aurait dû écouter ces gens
là savent et si ces gens là sont
intervenus ce moment là sans doute sauvé
des antennes dans la société et avait
probablement une autre perspective
et ces gens là n'ont pas été écoutés sur
huit
écoutez le match biaisé vaudrait oui oui
oui mais ne l'ont pas été alors qu'elle
avait des mesures de guerre là non
négociation vous it's a été bouclée
rapidement toute l'étape des funérailles
j'en sais ça s'est fait vite c'est un
pas il ya une instrumentalisation ici
pour vous vous savez enlèvement le 10
octobre
je veux jouer au ballon chasseur à saint
lambert chez des amis un peu plus tard
moi j'ouvre le téléviseur chez ses amis
là et je vois la maison chine et donc à
la télévision je vois la maison avec 2
300 personnes qui sont en face c'est là
que j'ai demandé qu'est-ce qui se passe
ils ont enfermé la télévision plan m'a
dit que ma soeur de venait me chercher à
ma soeur qui est un peu ce moment est
venu
on y retourne à la maison c'est là que
j'ai appris que mon père avait été
enlevé et on a rejoint la maison
beaucoup de monde la police un peu de
tout et c'est comme ça que ça a commencé
le 10 octobre
on s'est retrouvé au reine élizabeth ici
c'est ça qu'on est ici aujourd'hui
souvent ici aujourd'hui
l'équipe de robert bourassa est un étage
ou deux étages plus haut 11 et 12 des
communiqués pendant la semaine on
entendait l'information par la radio par
la télévision est un peu d'informations
qui venait aussi des représentants du
gouvernement
autant des ménisques que d'aidé attachée
politique si vous voulez 16 octobre des
mesures de guerre
quand je me suis réveillé je me rappelle
le matin puis les gens se coucher un peu
plus tard j'avais 11 ans je me suis
réveillé j'ai ouvert la télévision c'est
là que j'ai vu l'automobile avec la
valise ouverte et le corps de mon père
dans la valise de l'automobile c'est
comme ça que je souhaitais
il exactement 9h25 lacoste était
finalement ouvert et on y faisait avec
la découverte du corps de monsieur la
porte aussi un bulletin spécial
d'information c'est maintenant confirmé
le cadavre qui été découvert derrière la
voiture de marque chevrolet à
saint-hubert dans le coffre arrière donc
on vient d'annoncer que c'est le cadavre
de monsieur pierre laporte
je suis profondément thembu il
bouleversé par le crime ignoble dans tes
été victime de mon ami ont très bien
timé pierre bappel à 18 18 octobre au
matin est décédée
c'est l'objet du chanteur par la
télévision
et ça c'était le 18 au matin funérailles
le vin
tout est organisé tout est structuré
pour faire ça ma mère ne voulait pas que
les journalistes c'était des gens
suivent au niveau du de côte-des-neiges
parce qu'elle voulait garder ça vraiment
intime mais entre un dc10 cette
connaissance de 18 ans thermale de 20
est-ce que c'est précipité je vous dis
que c'est rapide ici d'un bon l'amateur
de gestionnaires joe drake d'une
situation tourner la page c'est
exactement ce que je ferai donc assez de
raid et le tout rapidement par la suite
le nom du pont au québec pire la porte
est venue très rapidement et je pense
que cette phase de l'histoire du québec
qui fut difficile pour les familles pour
la plupart des québécois on n'est pas
fier de ce qui est pas aussi au québec
en 1970 à son mode octobre on peut
tourner la page et passer à d'autres
choses
donc ça a été rapide et ça a été
organisé
je voudrais tout à fait à l'extérieur de
la famille parce que votre mère aussi la
plupart la télévision la mort de votre
père oui télévision nous regardez bien
informé parce que si vous vous rappelez
les communiqués étaient transmis aux
journalistes dans des poubelles à
montréal et 10 juin 10 où il cherchait
le communiqué s comme succès ça venait
ou non à nous en fonction des gens qui
le voyaient et qui disent merci
la famille elle est informée nom d'un
groupe très proche et quand vous perdez
pas dit la moitié de votre vie parce que
des enfants aussi mais l'être cher les
semaines avant l'enlèvement ma soeur et
moi monsieur presque est environ des
images in si c'était notre père ne
serait ce pas plutôt québec semaine
après ça arrive
alors si des situations qui fait peut
imaginer qu'ils sont arrivés à la
logique sera sans doute avec de très
grande émotion mais aussi avec l'espoir
et je pense qu'elle avait confiance au
gouvernement du québec pour négocier
parce que pierre laporte était
vice-premier ministre pierre laporte
avec travaillé avec jean lesage pour la
révolution tranquille chercher mener le
québec et on a mis cette défaite de la
course au leadership en soit 1,10
a été travaillé avec et pour robert
bourassa avec l'énergie qui a toujours
alors je pense qu'il était normal que
les négociations aient lieu je pense que
ma mère est confiante que les revoir son
mari ce qui est capital car pour elle
oui le vécu à tous les mois d'octobre et
de secrets dans toute sa vie alors oui
le véhicule senti puis donc pourquoi est
un sujet tabou probable le match ça fait
tellement mal
et lorsque vous savez pas le pourquoi
ou même le coma vous avez moins parler
mais pour moi vous parlez un peu pour
rien
reste avec moi mais si cet entretien
avec jean laporte poursuite c'est après
la pause façon d'être des pauvres
satisfaits et nous pourront siéger avec
compétence et efficacité aux endroits où
se prennent les décisions qui nous
concernent
autrement le québec continuera
rappelez-vous la description de gérard
filion être une fille entretenu il veut
pas assez pour vertueux
[Musique]
ils ont pas le droit de taire la vérité
aux québécois
je sors moi les gens qui survivent à
dire carrément ce qui s'est passé ils
ont pas le droit de séquestrer cette
histoire là appartient aux québécois
il faut parler en toute franchise il ya
toute ouverture à plus forte raison
cinquante ans plus tard il ya des voix
qui s'élèvent maintenant pour sauver les
survivants de la cellule chénier de
d'expliquer le geste parce que vous me
dire oh c'est pas le commun il ya aussi
tu as été confirmés dans des rapports
dans lequel un fameux communiqué qu'une
qu'ennemi rouen ce qu'on a appelé le
communiqué du drapeau blanc ou la
cellule libération qui détenait monsieur
kraus envoyer le message la cellule
chénier qui est de votre père nous
suspendons la menace de mort sur james
cross et les gens là ces libérations ont
toujours espérer que la cellule chénier
entende ce message là que ça ne va pas
aller si loin que ça et donc ce
communiqué leur est un des rares à ne
jamais avoir été diffusée donc parce que
la cellule chénier l'a jamais entendu on
peut penser qu'il vous donnera peut-être
pas tenu compte on n'est pas loin on ne
sait pas où on n'était pas là mais est
ce que c'est un élément plus ce fameux
communiqué n'ayant pas été suffisamment
ci avait été communiquée peut-être que
le québec et les québécois ont reçu que
au moins des cellules qui baisser la
tension
c'est quoi votre réaction je pense que
vous savez plus que moi que lorsqu'il ya
des situations de crise le contrôle de
l'information et cliquer ici ce
communiqué dont vous parlez ne pose été
publiés il ya quelqu'un quelque part qui
a pris la décision de ne pas le publier
et selon moi ce n'est sûrement pas la
police ce sont des décisions politiques
qui ont été prises parce que je crois à
la police je pense que ne sont pas des
décisions qui sont prises à ces niveaux
là alors ça ça confirme le fait que dans
une action politique est dans une
situation comme ça vous décidez un peu
de ce qui sort dans le gouvernement donc
et les gouvernements
on sacrifier votre père est devenu une
sorte de martyrs au fond vous deux oui
en même temps avec le recul on a appris
à quel point les autorités connaissaient
ces gens là qui étaient sous filature y
ont échappé à la police durant la
semaine
ils ont ils avaient des antécédents la
maison où était d'aider votre père était
connu n'a jamais été fou si on a line to
tous les faits qu'on peut qualifier
d'erreurs ou de bavure je te laisse le
public jugé quelle est votre réflexion
là dessus sur l'ailé le travail policier
en général c'est une suite d'erreurs
lorsque pierre laporte a été enlevé en
face de son domicile
mon cousin claude joue au football avec
lui est autant une tante louise
le peloton très bien vu les licences et
dans les cinq minutes qui suivaient la
police de saint lambert et sans doute
apprécié d'alès qui savez le genre de
voiture le numéro de la plaque
d'immatriculation ainsi que la couleur
et la direction risque était parti on
savait que ce n'est pas elle fournit
l'alliance de paul rose
on savait par des renseignements qui
était lié à la maison derrière moi je
peux pas urgent que l'homme ce que vous
disent que ce qui était dit à la police
est très rapidement enlèvement voiture
mais aux plaques de série et à partir de
là à rien s'est passé et comme vous
dites ils ont été à saint-hubert pour
nous c'est après qu'ils étaient quinze
minutes de la maison
n'ont jamais été trouvées et
l'information connue par la suite que
c'était déjà des endroits qui était
connu par la police plusieurs estiment
que la vraie crise d'octobre commence
avec un élément de votre père parce que
le représentant britannique ça faisait
pas assez et coup alors à leur cause
oui contre le colonialisme et bah c'est
pas assez de pouvoir de négociation et
pourtant votre père jouait au ballon
monsieur bourassa la semaine et à la new
york
avec le recul pensez vous qu'on avait
pris la pleine mesure de ce qui se
préparait au québec à ce moment-là de
cette crise
certains drapeaux parce que les
québécois ne sont pas des gens qui vont
je pense combattre un pull et les lits
des politiciens d'une façon agressive je
pense que les gens sont plus posés iem
la démocratie qui aiment ce qu'ils
vivent
alors qu'on s'attendait pas du tout à ça
au québec même si rien dans les mains
d'un diplomate auparavant alors non ce
n'était pas de promo sous le radar du
moins des gens mais le fait d'enlever un
vice-premier ministre le sait donner du
poids à leur cause certainement ça
donnait tout un pouvoir et en plus on
fait selon moi évidemment la grande
erreur d'enlever quelqu'un qui est un
nationaliste je crois je crois que dans
des usines où la majorité des ouvriers
en langue française il serait normal que
le contremaître quelques joies que le
patron je crois qu'en mesure de
s'adresser à ses employés dans leurs
mains pierre laporte était pour le fait
français pierre apportée pour le québec
et le canada mais le québec en premier
ils ont été enlevés quelqu'un qui
défendait la cause du québec plus que
n'importe qui à ce moment là d'un
gouvernement
avez vous l'impression que sa mort
oblitéré sa vie sa carrière de
journaliste
de combat dans qu'être nationaliste avec
laurent l'antre laurent dungu justement
parallèle à la victoire
c'est à nous de voir son opposition
deeply si je le fais pierre laporte et
pour la majorité des québécois
maintenant un pont une école un
boulevard et la crise d'octobre enlever
toute la carrière qui a mené pierre
laporte devenir vice premier ministre le
défenseur français quand il était
ministre au niveau des municipalités je
pense de laval je pense à ses différents
voyages autant au manitoba dans le
soutien donc aux états unis pour le
français il a à l'âge de 23 ans 24
recueilli délivre un wagons complets de
livres francophones pour l'envoyer au
manitoba et dans l'ouest du pays pour
aider les écoles qui ne pouvait pas se
permettre ça alors j'ai toujours été
dans l'action et tout ça est oublié le
jour de son assassinat parce que c'était
tellement gros pour le québec que le
carrier auparavant tué 17 ans aux
devoirs des journalistes d' enquête pour
le fait français
d'ailleurs on est tous reine elizabeth
c'est dans la biographie de jean charles
panneton qui documente le fait que votre
père a été aussi directeur de la revue
l'action nationale dans ses poches c'est
très nationaliste cloud et lancent une
pétition pour que le queen elizabeth
hôtel du sénat dont du canadien national
s'appelle châteaux maisons neuves
il pense et recueillir 5000 noms et on
obtient deux cent cinquante mille sa
bourde la chambre des communes l'on
changera pas mais c'est un conte boxe
c'est un exemple de convois qui l'omnis
il faut dire que dans ce temps là il y
avait énormément
l'organisation qui avaient des noms de
la fin et on les prononce heures alain
blaise au québec
ouais je pense que quand vous êtes
nationaliste vous devez aussi défendre
la langue et le plus possible ça devait
est un de ceux qu'on bosse pour que le
français soit une langue prioritaire
pour que nous ayons la capacité de
restaurer la qualité du français il faut
que ce soit une langue d'usagé courant
pour les 4 ou 5 e millions de personnes
qui parlent cette langue dans la
province de québec
[Musique]
pour prendre de l'éveil parce que ils
avaient ils avaient des liens
professionnels ou presque fraternels
avec ronnie et entendent bien ces deux
personnes ouais je pense qu'il
respectait des opinions on lisait pas
toujours d'accord mais je pense que peut
pas être un débiteur et il l'est mais
débattre d'idées pour faire évoluer
l'autre personne mais aussi lui même
dans des échanges d'idées et et les
débats les france qui grandissent à 200
mais votre père aussi défendu l'idée
d'un statut particulier pour le québec
est tout sauf à l'intérieur d'un
gouvernement lesage on dit que votre
père quand s'est joint à l'équipe lesage
il complétait l'équipe nationale
nationaliste que jean-charles cantonné
aux nationalistes des gérin lajoie jeu
lille est il apparu qui a vu quand il a
mis le 22/07 particulier puis monsieur
lesage pour tous aimer ça rappelez vous
le maître chez nous wen en maîtres chez
nous et peut-être sont un peu diluée
mais c'est tout de même fait gagner des
élections plaidé maître chez nous
intéressant je pense que tous les
québécois puis maîtres chez-nous moi je
crois en ce jeu commence au québec qu'au
canada au sommet c'est elle elle un peu
nationaliste parti libéral suite
un monsieur du plessis et je pense que
c'était bon pour québec d'avoir se
mettre en branle pour relancer
l'économie
ce gouvernement à la révolution
tranquille s'est occupée des écoles des
routes
la chaussée ce qui la polytechnique a
été un grand chambardement qui ont
permis au québec de se démarquer dans le
futur alors c'était probablement une
pause si mal donc mais aussi et il avait
prôné l'idée du français langue
prioritaires et ça aussi monsieur lesage
de pas trop d'accord avec ça si je me
fie la biographie de jean charles ton
il est absolument anormal que 80% du
citoyen qui parlent le français soit en
fait
propriétaire d'une langue qui non
seulement n'a pas de statut prioritaire
mais qui est un menacé de disparition
par chat mauvaise qualité
je pense que pour le québec c'est un peu
normal mais c'est arrivé
pas mal plus tard dans des années où le
français devenu prioritaire
on n'a pas encore aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on est tout bon niveau entre le
français l'anglais maintenant d'autres
au québec et j'ai retenu l extrait jelly
de penneteau votre père était candidat
indépendant dans laurier est appuyé par
les gens du devoir le gendre
nous sommes devenus un peuple à petit
salaire à drummondville à québec à bali
fil partout dans la province où le
salaire moyen de 500 dollars inférieur à
celui des autres provinces
nous offrons le spectacle lamentable des
plus riches provinces qui gît à la queue
de la confédération au point de vue
économique et industriel c'est un tier
discours cfoot
vous me pardonnerez fermé mais sur le
fond il luttait contre les inégalités
sociales d'autres lutter pour la lutte
des classes mais les moyens n'a pas les
mêmes parce que sur le fond des choses
et 10 laurendeau dunton dans son rapport
dont elle disait qu'ils se calment les
arguments qu'on retrouve dans le
manifeste sur d'inégalité d'injustice
il était là pour est ce qu'on peut se
combattre ou améliorer le mieux être
améliorée que combattre
mais il avait il est à la bonne place il
y avait les outils pour le faire alors
je crois foncièrement qu'il aurait pu
améliorer le québec et s'attaquer à
certaines causes que les felquistes
voulait faire et me direz au québec la
raison selon moi attaqué au maroc homme
qui lui voulait grandement amélioré le
français l'économie
le québec en soient maîtres chez nous
c'était tout ça quand on sait que c'est
sa mort est oblitéré sa vie ce qu'il a
fait il ya même été candidat aux côtés
de jean drapeau il ya il a mené le
contre la corruption contre les crimes
organisés soit dans les années 50 le
journal le devoir c'est son enquête à
l'ue publie le scandale du verre naturel
qui impliquait du ministre du
gouvernement
ça vous inspire quoi mais c'est
intéressant de voir un journaliste
enquête est ce qu'on me disait ce qu'il
travaillait acharnement ses heures par
jour et adresse creuser mais et qu'il
avait des bons contacts avec plusieurs
personnes pour recevoir cette
information alors pour lui permettre de
continuer ses recherches
mais je pense aussi comme journaliste
était très précis
et lorsqu'il voyait un scandale il
n'hésitait pas à la mise sur la place
publique que ce soit d'un fonctionnaire
ou du 1er mai laisse par exemple mais ça
n'amène quand même un sujet délicat
je sais pas si vous voyez venir c'est
qu'après sa mort lieu une allégation
d'un policier a rebondi à l'assemblée
nationale
l'information selon laquelle votre père
participer à une réunion en avril 1970
avec deux mafieux dans un bureau avez
vous l'impression que cette histoire a
nui à la mémoire de votre père
la commission de police toujours de bien
rapporté par penneteau complètement
blanchi votre père mais il est déjà
qu'ils peuvent penser car la porte saint
mathieu
comment oublier les histoires quand vous
regardez de crise d'octobre
ça peut être un lien logique pour
enlever le blâme des personnes complices
des décisions qui ont amené la fin de
crise d'octobre
et tout ça a été démenti par la suite et
c'est il a été sympa cent blanchi et je
pense que les deadlines oncle et les
journaux et les nouvelles ont beaucoup
plus parlé de la première partie où il a
été attaqué sans pour se défendre parce
qu'ils étaient décédés versus le fait
qu'il a été bref blanchi qui a pas été
comme en première page non plus là il
faut vous mettre les choses en
perspective merci de me permettre de le
faire dans le sens où il faut que vous
êtes blanchi je pense que ça devrait
être amené dans dans les livres
d'histoire aussi si vous parlez de la
première étape mais est ce que ça vous
rend doublement victime comme famille de
pensée d'avariés mort à 70 et les
conséquences de tuer deux fois dans ma
bulle et s'est dit c'est un homme qui a
été admiré moi je le dis publiquement a
j'ai milité pour votre père à 16 ans
espérait devenir premier ministre du
québec
bon mais elle espère devenir plus mince
du québec et je crois
après mes lectures je vais 11 en ce
moment là que avec le support qui le
donnait à jean lesage et qu'il est
toujours été très fidèle à la ligne du
parti
hier jean lesage qui étaient deux chefs
du parti disent pas qu'ils méritaient le
devenir chef mais il était normal se
présente et qu'il espère pouvoir le
devenir il ya été je pense un très bon
soldat
becks partout dans cette biographie on
voit qui était le bras droit de jean
lesage avant même qu'ils soient
ministres
mais gilles lesage journalistes de voir
signe la préface il dit la rumeur percer
ses gonds bien dessinés à l'autre la
suspicion terni un bilan honorable
il n'en déplaise aux justiciers
manichéen aux inquisiteurs sommaire n'a
pu se défendre et les commissaires là
comme son police disent que c'est un
coup monté qui a été piégé parce que si
tu quand même ironique il a des qui est
élu député il obtient la mise en tutelle
de ville jacques cartier
d'où viennent les roses quand il plaide
pour la classe ouvrière et jacques
cartier mère qui est rémillard qui
avaient des roches différentes
oui mais il l'a pris comme un casier
judiciaire dont il fait mettre en
tutelle de jacques cartier
quand ils viennent les affaires
municipales et rend inéligibles les gens
qui ont des casiers judiciaires à des
postes électifs
c'est une préoccupation pour lui c'est
un homme droit un homme droit quand vous
voyez ça il dit c'est pour ça que le
québec mérite et je pense que les lois
qui ne fait pas c'était pour un peu
nettoyer l'histoire de certains
politiciens autant municipal qu'au
provincial et c'est ce qui l'a amenée et
déjà quartier c'est à une rude métier
nous l'a alors c'est tout une décision à
prendre de faire ça quand vous habitez
juste à côté
c'est dans sa circonscription oui oui
oui
donc je boucler la boucle sur ce thème
là difficile donc de faire moins
quelqu'un deux fois mais ce samedi deux
fois et en plus c'est un peu est ce que
ça vous habitez surtout téléchargement
trouvé ça pas de s'attaquer à quelqu'un
qui est décédé qui propose des vins à ce
moment là folie vous s'il vous plaît
respectez les mares et il le fait que ça
a été monté de toutes pièces et blanchis
par la suite garder ça dans l'histoire
c'est simplement je pense faire le jeu
de certains manipulateurs comme ça en
place reste avec mon ami sur cet
entretien avec jean laporte poursuite ou
se tapent à la porte
quand votre père meurt rené lévesque
aurait agi j'aimerais ça qu'on écoute
ensemble vous vous en souvenez de la
déclaration
ceux qui croient demant et délibérément
exécutées monsieur laporte après l'avoir
vu vivre et espéré pendant 30 jours sont
des être inhumains
ils ont importé ici dans une société qui
ne justifie absolument pas fanatisme
glacial et des méthodes de chantage à
l'assassinât qui sont celles d'une
jungle sans issue
si leur sauvagerie reflét aient si peu
que ce soit le vrai québec on voudrait
s'en aller à jamais le plus loin
possible
sur le seul évêque
je pense qu'il représentait bien ce que
les
la majorité des québécois pensent à ce
moment là où le flq était trop loin et
c'est assez clair ce qu'il faisait
l'avez-vous réentendu souvent ces textes
à nos citoyens
c'est dans les axes suivants plus là oui
oui père est l'âme il se donne un frère
politique quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui l'avait qu'il a discuté il
on pense un peu créé d'euros québec
l'ensemble mais par la suite on était
dans différents partis mais le respect
toujours là malgré des perspectives
différentes un respect des deux côtés ça
j'ai appris de ça c'est la consternation
et avec un profond bouleversement que
les canadiens ont appris la mort de
pierre laporte assassiné lâchement par
une bande d'assassins en tant que
canadiens j'ai le sentiment de honte
devant un geste aussi cruel exécuté avec
tant de sang froid et perfidie et je
voudrais simplement dire au nom du
gouvernement canadien et du peuple
canadien je voudrais dire à madame la
porte
la famille de monsieur pierre laporte la
profonde sympathie et l'émotion qui nous
bouleverse
je leur souhaite beaucoup de courage il
monsieur trudeau
c'est bien dit c'est bien dit mais je
pense aussi qu'il avait entre les mains
la vie de pierre laporte et que sa
tournée de manière que l'on connaît et
c'est par la suite c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à régler dont l'appel de sucre
50 à plus tard parce que vous êtes
nombreux à pouvoir parler de ce qui
s'est passé qui veulent connaître
vraiment ce qui s'est passé at il
seulement par accident os est exécuté de
sang froid
est ce que c'est important pour vous pas
du tout pas du tout parce que il aima
ait été assassiné il ya 50 ans savoir le
qui le comment le pourquoi ne leur
demande pas ne confonds enfance ne
remonte pas un grand père pour mes
enfants
le vide est là et vous allez pas remplir
un vide avec de l'information parce que
c'est le lien humain qui manque c'est le
contact c'est c'est le fait qu'ils
soient là alors l'information manque un
peu intéressante pour l'histoire du
québec
mais pour la famille du moins pour moi
la page ne sera jamais tourné parce que
jamais de retour mais on doit cheminot
doit grandir et je doit permettre à mes
enfants et à mon épouse d'avoir québec
un canadair simple pour m'accrocher à
octobre ça fait octobre 110 pas ça fait
trop mal parce qu'en même temps les gens
disent qu'ils sont refuse de le dévoiler
c'est comme si on poursuivait dans la
même idéologie le même discours
je ne dis pas qu'on doit pas dévoiler
enfin demandé ce que pour moi c'est
important
et pour finir en s'intéressant mais pour
moi non parce que le cheminement
dû se faire sans sors et je ne pouvais
pas attendre que cela sort pour cheminer
faire ma carrière vivre ma vie qu'est ce
que ça voulait dire être le fils de
pierre laporte ses amis à 15h24 à 20 ans
j'étais le fils de lehman universités on
m'appelait le fils de et fait un art
droit et de fils jett en droit et de la
décidé de changer de branche pour aller
en finance en économie ou jean laporte
jean laporte alors les gens ne font pas
n'ont pas fait de lien entre l'homme
d'affaires et le politicien et pour moi
ça me permettait d'opérer et de me
prouver et non plus uniquement le fils
de m le gestionnaire est le leader
le coach des employés ce volet
mais le fils de pierre laporte espère
t-il quinze jours l'histoire nous donne
à son père la place qui lui revient
tout à fait ça ne sera pas aujourd'hui
parce que pierre laporte c'est plus que
les crises octobre c'est comme un
appariteur un politicien c'est ce qu'on
compare laisser le livre très
intéressant et je remercie monsieur
panneton pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a fait
est normal de recherche et grâce à ça je
vais appeler sont nombreux craignez-vous
par ailleurs que certains veulent
continuer d'aider alizés la crise
d'octobre comme étant tout à fait sûr
tous n'ont pas vécu quand des gens se
rapprochent de la crise
un supporter les actions qui ont été
posées ou bien comprendre ce qu'ils font
ou bien je pense que accepter la
violence au québec n'est certainement
pas
la route que je prendre pour moi même
pour mes enfants pour leurs enfants
qu'est ce que voudrait qu'on retienne de
pierre laporte bon père de famille
présents drôle plein d'énergie
intellectuelle mais engagée puis qui
voulait changer son monde pour
l'améliorer édiles fait français et
améliorer le québec pense vice premier
ministre quand vous avez cheminée comme
ça comme journaliste autant québec qu'à
ottawa
vous avez des connaissances qui peuvent
à aider des gens qui veulent grandir et
c'est ça serait le souvenir que je
voudrais partager
est-ce quelque chose que je voulais j'ai
terminé merci de me permettre de parler
de pierre laporte
l'homme politique lui même le père de
famille et de tout ce qu'il a été
monsieur laporte merci beaucoup merci à
vous
et là messieurs merci nous avons suivi à
la prochaine voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]